oh if only bees made me as cool as Peter
Capaldi I seriously thought about
keeping the sunglasses going for the
whole review but figure probably
extracting so extremity extremists well
whatever
episode six of series 10 of Doctor Who
and I liked it wasn't I'm amazing but I
thought it was good I thought it was all
I thought it for what it was and it was
one of those concepts that could really
go either way and really just fall apart
I thought it was well executed for what
it was trying to do I think it did a lot
of stuff really well without having
anything that I thought completely fell
down obviously sort of the base thing we
now have our answer what's in the vault
Missy's in the vault now that's not
exceptionally surprising I think a lot
of people had speculated that some
version of the master was going to be
inside that vault
I do like that it didn't feel like the
episode was playing bat like it was a
twist it did it didn't really get to the
confirmation absolute that that's what
it was until the very end of the episode
but it seemed implied pretty heavily as
soon as she showed up out probably going
to turn out to be her and it never it
never pretended like revealing that was
pulling the rug out from the audience it
seemed to understand that I think that
that kind of approach in general goes a
long way to selling the episode just
presenting us with the stuff but not it
never felt like it was going hot we got
you because it wouldn't have and and
because it doesn't try and pull that
kind of weight with what it's doing I
thought it works um I I like Missy I
have liked Missy from the beginning I
and I like having her back so just
seeing her interactions even these
little bits I really like I love nardole
in this one I said I liked Nardo before
I like the glimpses of had a snarl and I
liked it basically it's like the
strength of this mandate for River is
what gives him the power to have those
badass moments I like that
I like that connection back to river and
his connection to her which is something
that hasn't been I think properly
acknowledged up at this point but I like
I like that connection being drawn built
well maybe that might be my one
complaint build slightly superfluous to
this episode um can't drag it down or
anything but she didn't she didn't there
was not much that she did that was
beyond what they could have done with
just nardole but um which I'm she was
fine Palli compiled he was good about
he's always good I I like that the sonic
sunglasses came back I like the way that
they were used I like that he was able
to get information but but they didn't
actually because I saw um in the comment
section of my last video or I talked to
you know I wonder how it the blindness
is going to play out yo people like well
you got the sonic sunglasses could
probably be like sonar it's like you can
see I'm glad I wasn't someone like that
but at the same time the doctor does
have access to crazy technology that he
does have some kind of workaround I
think it was a nice balance of
acknowledging that you know between his
own know-how and the technology that he
had he has at his fingertips that he
can't come up with something but that he
is still handicapped by this and it
still don't hold him back and be a
detriment I think that's a pretty good
balance of acknowledging what he's
capable of while still burdening him
with this new disability I like the way
the whole reveal of the artificial world
was handled because when you have that
initial set up of this like this
document and this truth that anyone who
reads it whether they're a person of
faith a person of science no matter what
they will want to die that's a that's a
big mystery is one of those things like
is there any answer to that that's
actually going to feel like you properly
justified that reaction and honestly
yeah the way it presents in the way it
presents through the revelation and I
like that that's the doctor reference
SuperMario as the point of reference is
like what if you realized he was in a
game and he just got sick of dying and
removed himself from it that I think
that was that was a neat comparison
I think it it just the way that it was
revealed between using the numbers and
and having is realized just the full
extent of what it was we were looking at
just sort of reveal and sink in over
time I think helped sell the premise
because I think again it is one of those
things that I think if it's not properly
worked into the story and if it the
information is all revealed in the
proper fashion it's the sort of thing
that can just make you go this is dumb
and for me that can happen I like to
quite a bit I really love the ending um
with the the artificial the construct
doctor for lack of a better term you
know with oh I'm just I'm going to do
what everyone does in the world in
danger I'm going to call the doctor and
he sends off the information and just
like grin Capaldi is really good at the
triumphant smug moment that the doctor
gets and all the doctors have had them
but he's he's been really good and I
love what he has it just that I win that
grin in that sense of I won and I love
that and I love the the just if you stop
and think about that this thing isn't
the doctor and it realizes it isn't but
it's still going to pay and do what the
doctor would do and bring him is
actually help now how this pans out from
here um could be iffy is the first thing
that leaps to mind is sort of the follow
on the silence now the silence I liked a
lot and we got our initial revealed them
and I felt like subsequent appearances
from them they weren't bad but they
didn't quite hold up as much and I'm
worried that these sort of rotted
Cardinals looking things whatever they
are that runs the same risk that once we
get to finding out you know what their
deal is proper it's going to be kind of
a oh okay so it's that and and I it's
one of the things that makes you they'd
be better off leaving us with more
questions than answers but we'll see it
will also depend on what those answers
medli are Oh what I think that's about
it is I like it I didn't I didn't love
it but I liked what I saw I thought it
was well executed for what it was there
was nothing that was the fire zone that
part that part didn't work like I said
the closest thing was bill and even that
she wasn't bad she just wasn't necessary
um except insofar as she's the companion
so get she there um but it was it was
good and it was intriguing and it was
clever and I will be really interested
to see oh you know what's the other
thing that I do want to single out
because I thought it was a brilliant
concept just the idea of this planet
with these people their job is to keep a
catalogue of every way to kill every
species that's just a really cool
concept and I always have kind of a
morbid fascination with that kind of a
job where your job is something either
insane or horrific but it's just like
this is my job this is my thing that I
do I always kind of find that
fascinating so I like the vibe we got up
that sort of execution airy guy and I
like it got overused for a little while
but it's been a while since the doctor
has pulled you know in effect though I'm
the doctor look me up thing he hasn't
pulled that in a while I think we were
we were due for it it was it was the
right time to pull it again and that
will end that was a good moment because
it's been long enough since the last
time he did that is like yeah yeah it's
on record how much trouble you're in of
you is this guy off don't go there
so I think that was the last thing that
I wanted to remember to talk about so
your thoughts on extremis extremity
romerito fair whatever the heck it
actually is pronounced as what were your
thoughts whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a dumb forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council geese give a listen to the
council geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]